peace in ukraine feels a long way away
but negotiations between russia and
ukraine are ongoing
the talks are continuing it's a process
that is not stopping but at the moment
it has no relationship to what's going
on the front line
so what would it take for both sides to
lay down their weapons
[Music]
we've been discussing how much to make
of all this talk about peace talks you
know are they serious is president putin
serious do we have the contours of what
a peace deal might look like
and i guess i'm going to start with you
ed um because what do you make of all
this chatter
um do you think the sort of the outlines
of a peace deal when the time is right
are becoming clear or is it all really
premature well i think sadly there are
i think about
what a peace deal involves i think there
are kind of three sets of things the
first thing is the status the peace
status of ukraine the second
is the sequencing of the lifting of
sanctions
and the third and i think the trickiest
is what happens to the land that russia
has taken there's that whole um area of
land in the south of ukraine by the cia
of azov which joins
crimea to russia across the land and
that is extraordinary valuable land for
russia uh but it's also very important
for ukraine as access to the sea and
ukraine exports large amounts of
agricultural goods
um and so if you if you think of those
three things needed to get a peace deal
actually if you take the totality we
haven't got very far down that path one
has to look at who's doing the
negotiating here
and i think the ukrainian side has got
real authority to negotiate but the
russian side well you know
russia's foreign minister
lavrov only knew about the invasion the
night before the invasion happened he
really hasn't and the people under him
really haven't got the authority to
negotiate there'll be one person who
decides uh when peace is to be done and
that's vladimir putin so let's just pick
up on a couple of those so one in terms
of the status of ukraine so if nato
membership is out of the question
zolensky has accepted that too what are
the models we should be thinking about
for a
security guarantee that would make a
kind of
neutrality agreement work that's what
point one and point two
um what do you think is
likely given where the two sides are
militarily in terms of ukraine's
willingness to
allow russia to keep any of that
territory whether it's give up claims on
crimea or will the russians demand more
than that
zanny i i
and i've been thinking about this i
can't think of any
post-war
modern example of a country which has
freely accepted such onerous terms of
the thought the kremlin is demanding
that is not just neutrality but also
demilitarization uh stringent
constraints on the size and nature of
the armed forces limitations on security
blocks i think the most important
question is going to be
how sizable an armed force will ukraine
retain and how much western support in
the form that it's been getting the last
several weeks will it continue to have
that's the finnish model of armed
neutrality making itself indigestible
and i think that's probably one of the
most important routes for
for ukraine to follow
you asked a question also about
ukraine's willingness to give up
territory that it loses in this campaign
and i think you know in the last couple
of days we've seen ukrainian negotiators
say they will not accept any loss of
pre-war territory and they won't
recognize any russian sovereignty over
pre-1991
territory so in other words they won't
even recognize russian sovereignty over
crimea which was lost in 2014 when it
was annexed and i think what's happened
the last month or so since we have been
having these webinars is the ukrainians
feel they are winning they feel suddenly
that they can actually outlast russia
here and that i think is going to make
them very resistant to making any sort
of territorial concessions unless the
course of the conflict on the ground
changes fundamentally as well so that
means that even those elements which we
read about as being the sort of
component elements of any any cease-fire
stroke peace agreement seem to be much
much harder than than they appear at
first sight and then of course al-qaeda
there's the the russian perspective on
this and and vladimir putin i think we
all now agree can't win in the sense
that he thought he was going to win very
you know quickly
going in very quickly and taking ukraine
but he also surely can't afford to
completely lose he can't afford to be
humiliated domestically so what will it
take before he is willing to countenance
coming to some agreement and what are
the sort of what has to be in that
agreement for him to be able to claim
victory domestically that's a very good
question zany uh
to answer it can we just make a step
back
uh and look at the objectives of this
special operation uh
russia of course was not threatened by
ukraine it didn't wasn't really
concerned with security of russia uh
from a threat from ukraine uh russia's
nuclear power he was not really
concerned about the threat military
threat from the west
uh i think a lot of the drivers of this
war of this war uh were
internal and domestic they had to do
with putin's uh weakening legitimacy his
need to stay in power
his delusion of
grandeur and historic statue his legacy
that's what led him into this war
into this blunder
in some ways
ending this war for him would be very
easy because uh one of the key
objectives that he set out dealing
suffocation and demilitarization uh of
ukraine well demilitarization sort of
has been partly achieved uh purely
through the damage that he is uh
inflicted on the ukrainian forces as for
denuncification nothing is easier than
to achieve that because nuts has never
existed in ukraine so he could stop that
absolutely any moment he is
consolidating power he is turning as we
said russian totalitarian society he is
cutting it from the west he could
actually sell pretty much anything at
home uh the problem is that he got
himself into a war
uh where he is not the only one who
decides we we um have often worked
ourselves into this sort of state of
mind because of the uh pure violence
this man is is ready to unleash
that you know we get sort of
not now but in the past almost sort of
paralyzed thinking if he's doing this he
will succeed
let's just remember that not everything
he wants he gets uh not in everything he
starts he succeeds putin has never
believed and that has been the biggest
weakness single biggest weakness of his
regime and the um
terrible thing that he done in russia is
he doesn't believe in the will and
agency of the people he plans things in
his mind he thinks once he's planned
them they will um go according to plan
as he keeps repeating they're gay
according to plan the idea and but a war
is not a parade a war is not a rally
that he can stage inside moscow uh with
uh with flag waving and the ukrainians
do show they have agencies in a way the
fate of russia and and therefore the
fate of europe is actually being decided
today by ukrainians on the battlefield
after last week's webinar i asked you
for some uh
advice on books to read about putin and
you said the absolute best possible book
that you can read is putin in his own
words it's called putin's own words um
which i really really recommend to
anybody who's watching this um it's a
book that was written on the basis of
hours and hours of interviews with putin
when he in when he first
came to power and in it there is the
story of the rat
um which is a very telling story i think
of putin and and how he sees the world
he apparently when he was a child in
leningrad as it was then called he one
of the things he and his friends would
do would be to chase rats in the in the
stair block of his uh communal apartment
block and one day he chased a very large
rat into a corner and that cornered rat
flew at his throat and chased him and he
said i learned one of the most important
life lessons at that moment but arkady
you know is is putin like the cornered
rat now i don't think he does yet feel
as a as a cornered rat there is another
very important uh bit in that book
uh which directly relates to what we've
been talking about and the story which
he tells us that of uh his kgb file
and why uh he was not promoted higher up
within the ranks of the kgb he actually
was very low ranking serving officer uh
in the gdr and the two things that were
entered on his file by people who
interview examine these people you know
psychologically assess them are two
traits that stop him rising is one was
his recklessness and the second was the
lack of empathy he believed uh i'm
pretty convinced of that that the
nuclear threat the threat of him
uh putting russian nuclear arsenal on
high alert uh him threatening
entertaining the thought of using
tactical military weapon will have the
west back off and that will be his most
important card that he could not lose
at any point because he can always say
i'm going to do this i'm going to to use
uh
my nuclear card if we're right in
thinking this is what he's counted on
that he will pull out the card and the
west will back off uh how does that
change dynamic on the battlefield i
don't think he will use that uh easily
not least because his own entourage uh
might have signed up for kleptocracy
might have signed up even you know
doesn't have really much choice but to
continue to back him but to do this to
not just themselves to go to the hague
but
uh have their children and grandchildren
potentially die i don't think they have
much appetite for that
thank you for watching for all our
coverage on the war in ukraine please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe